In Florida.
Take a
look at this packed
event hosted by a bookstore.
It's not a book signing.
People that were there
last night to support former
national youth poet
laureate Amanda Gorman,
who donated
1200 books to be given out,
including 400 copies of her book
and two other titles
restricted at a Miami-Dade
County public school for kindergarten
through eighth graders.
The books are being restricted to
after one parents complaint.
Gorman's book is titled The Hill
We Climb.
It's the same title as the poem
she read at President
Biden's inauguration
in 2021 as the youngest inaugural poet
in U.S. history.
Months later, her book was published
and had been available
at the school library for all students
until one parents complaint.
And by the way, that parent
did not actually read the book
Now, the school district says only middle
school students have access
to Amanda Gorman's book.
The parents complaint stated it
includes, quote, hate messages
The parent took issue
with just some lines, Gorman recited.
Here are a few of them.
We've braved the belly of the beast.
We've learned
that quiet isn't always peace
in the norms and notions of what just is
isn't always just is.
And yet the dawn is hours before
we knew it.
Somehow we do it.
Somehow we've weathered and witnessed
a nation that isn't broken
but simply unfinished.
And Amanda Gorman joins us now.
And so we're just hearing you do that
inaugural poem again. It's lovely.
It's great to have you back.
And I'm sorry to say, the circumstances
when you've heard this
What was your initial reaction
when you found out this,
that your book is being restricted
by somebody
who had not actually even read it?
Hmm.
I think my first response
was this dual experience
of shock and grief
for the first part,
because over 40 million people
saw that moment at the inauguration.
And I couldn't imagine a reason
of erasing that
from a bookshelf
for young readers to see.
And on the flip side,
I felt this
anguish and pain
because so much of the excitement
that I had while writing The Hill
We Climb was knowing
that young people would be able to see
themselves represented
in this moment in our democratic history.
And so to have that representation
taken away from young people
just felt devastating.
You know,
this is happening
obviously, in places across the country.
And often it's
parents who have not read
any of these books.
They often
just get a list of books
from an organization,
a conservative organization
that wants books removed.
And they send that in
and to show up at a school board meeting
and the books are taken out.
I think you get
absolutely to
the core of the issue, which is that
you can, in effect, ban restrict
remove a book like that.
All it takes
is one person
often who isn't a parent
or doesn't even need to read that work
to sign a complaint
and that complaint can be accomplished
pretty quickly, as we saw with
what happened with my book.
That form
can even be filled out inaccurately
and that can still lead to that
book being restricted for that school,
that community, that library.
And so what we're
witnessing is a real loophole
in the educational system
where it's really easy to mobilize
a small select group of people
to ban thousands of books over time.
Now, to get your book,
you've got to go to the media center
and you have to in the school,
you have to prove
that you're at a fifth grade
reading level in order
to get access to the book.
That's kids
aren't going to discover
a book like that.
No, I think you're absolutely correct.
And one of the things
that keeps getting set
around the circumstance of my book
that's been banned
and other books that were removed
from the elementary school
shelves at that same school
due to that same complaint,
a lot of what gets said
is, oh, it's not banned.
It's just moves to the elementary side,
to the middle school.
But what you have to keep in
mind, exactly like what you said,
if a child
now needs to jump over hurdles
of going to a different location,
speaking to a media specialist,
proving themselves
worthy and ready of reading a book.
Those types of hurdles
are going to
really impede students
from having a free, ranging,
welcoming experience of being able
to pull a book from a bookshelf
and experience it.
And what you just said
also about the role of parent.
I am totally accepting and at peace
with the fact
that not every parent,
not every guardian
is going to like my work.
And I think that's absolutely par
for the course.
But I think the issue is
when one person's dislike
for my work
leads to everyone else,
not having access to that book.
We're really encroaching
on the rights of families and parents
and teachers and libraries
to really create access for that
that exist
for other people
who still want that door.
You know,
there've been a lot of questions
about the motivation behind
a number of these people
who are doing this in school districts.
Our correspondent
Ellie Reeve, actually went to a mom's
for Liberty School
Board meeting,
which is becoming a nationwide group
of of of of people who are behind this
and talked to a leader of a
of a group from Moms for Liberty.
I just want to play
some of what she had to say
To me, it sounds like
you're saying
there's some kind of high level
coordinated effort
to make more children trans and good.
Yeah.
Well, who's directing that?
Teachers unions and
our president
and a lot of funding sources and teachers
unions are also heavily backing
the curriculum
that we're bringing into school.
Why would they want more kids
to be gay and trans?
Because it breaks down the family unit,
which breaks down
traditional conservative values.
It breaks down a lot of things
in this country
that it changes
the way that people think.
It changes
the way that people handle politics.
Which is sort of a fascinating unpeeling
of the onion
that at the core
for this woman in particular,
she believes this is part of a conspiracy
by teacher unions and others to
to destroy conservative values
and destroy the American family.
Does that make any sense to you?
It absolutely makes
sense to me
and explains
why we've seen such an increase
in spike in book bans over the past
few years.
For example,
out of the 2500 plus book bans
that we saw
last year, the majority of them,
according to The Washington
Post, came from just 11 people.
And so what we're seeing
is that
this book, Banning, isn't representative
of the opinions
and instincts
of most parents, teachers, students,
but from a really small subset of people
who believe
that they're protecting children
from indoctrination.
Of ideas,
of race, of gender, of sexuality.
But at the end of the day,
what they're ultimately doing
is eradicating the freedom of children
and students from exploring those issues
in a safe
and protected and educational space
that can be combined
with the love of learning and reading.
You're also partnering
with PEN America to help
others speak out against book banning.
How can people help?
Absolutely.
So if you want to learn more
about book
restrictions and removals
and also how you can have
your voice heard,
you can visit pen dot org slash action.
We've made a webpage there
where you can get all the information
you need about standing up.
All right. Amanda Gorman, thanks so much.
Thank you.